et cela intervient alors que l'armée
russe est en passe de prendre le
contrôle du port stratégique de
marioupol sur la mer d'azov à les
soldats ukrainien pour l'instant
continue de résister mais pour combien
de temps d'autant que la russie pourrait
avoir recours à des armes chimiques pour
les déloger c'est en tout cas ce
qu'affirment plusieurs sources
ukrainienne accès mais bonjour est ce
que cette utilisation d'armes chimiques
par les russes et crédible en tout cas
le chef de la diplomatie américaine
anthony blinken a apporté rapporté cette
semaine des informations crédibles sur
la possibilité que la russie et fassent
usage d'agents chimiques dans son
offensive pour prendre cette ville
portuaire de mario paul et jusqu'à
présent lorsque blink elle par la une se
base sur les services de renseignement
américains et jusqu'à présent lorsque
les services de renseignement américains
ont dit quelque chose sur la situation
en ukraine et sur le conflit qui oppose
la russie l'ukraine et bien ses services
au plus tôt et est fiable alors il
pourrait s'agir a poursuivi anthony
blinken de gaz lacrymogène mélangés avec
des agents chimiques l'utilisation de
gaz lacrymogènes permettant de masquer
plus ou moins la présence d'agents
chimiques toxiques évidemment un moscou
comme à chaque fois qu'il ya des
accusations graves portées contre ses
troupes dément joe biden lui a prévenu
que l'usagé de telles armes chimiques en
ukraine susciterait une réponse des
etats-unis sans en préciser la nature
c'est aussi une manière un vous l'aurez
compris pour moscou de tester la
réaction des occidentaux
et puis contrairement à la série par
exemple les occidentaux se sont gardé de
fixer une ligne rouge à ne pas franchir
accès ce qui est important c'est que ce
n'est pas la première fois que les
russes sont soupçonnées d'utiliser des
armes interdites par les conventions
internationales
oui on pense évidemment à la convention
sur l'interdiction ou là où la
limitation de l'emploi de certaines
armes classiques qui peuvent être
considérées comme produisant des effets
traumatiques excessifs comme frappant
sans discrimination la phrase est un peu
long mais al explique bien ce dont il
s'agit
ça c'est une convention signée à genève
en 1981 et ça c'est le cadre général et
puis ya eu des protocoles d'autres
conventions qui se sont rajoutés ainsi
l'entrée en vigueur la convention sur
l'interdiction des armes chimiques dont
on parle potentiellement à marioupol et
bien date de 1997 il ya aussi les armes
à sous-munitions qu'aurait utilisé dans
des zones peuplées les russes convention
qui date de 2008 seulement hélas selon
michelle bachelet la haute commissaire
aux droits de l'homme de l'onu des armes
à sous munitions ont été utilisés dans
les zones peuplées au moins 24 fois
depuis le début du conflit dont vous
voyez c'est assez chiffré et quand on
parle de bombes à sous-munitions bien là
aussi ça veut dire ce que ça veut dire
ce sont par exemple un obus qui sert de
conteneurs quand il explose il ya plein
de petites munitions qui se répartissent
sur une large zone avec souvent les
civils qui sont touchés à noter
toutefois que ni moscou ni kiev n'ont
signé la convention interdisant les
armes à sous-munitions et qu'il ya aussi
les l'emploi de bombes au phosphore
reconnaissable aux traînées blanches
dans le ciel qu'elle laisse un
particularité de ces armes incendiaires
les bombes au phosphore un leur usage
est interdit contre des civils et pas
contre des cibles militaires c'est toute
la difficulté des lois de la guerre des
armes interdites par des pays ne le sont
pas par d'autres interdite certaines
armes dans certaines circonstances ne le
sont pas dans d'autres circonstances et
je terminerai en disant qu amnesty
international tente de documenter les
attaques russes et prévient qu'elle
pourrait constituer des crimes de guerre
en raison des frappes aveugles sur les
civils et en raison de l'utilisation
d'armes non discriminant c'est-à-dire
d'armes qui ne font pas la part la
distinction entre les cibles civiles et
les cibles militaires merci axel mais
pour pour cet éclairage